we're asked what is the equation of line
B and they tell us that line a has an
equation y is equal to 2x plus 11 and
they say that the line B contains the
point 6 negative 7 and they tell us
lines a and B are perpendicular
perpendicular so that means that slope
slope of B must be negative inverse of
slope of a slope of a so what we'll do
is we'll figure out the slope of a then
take the negative inverse of it then
we'll know the slope of B then we can
use this point right here to fill in the
gaps and figure out B's y-intercept so
what's the slope of a this is already in
slope-intercept form the slope of a is
right there
it's the two MX plus B so the slope here
is equal to 2 so the slope of a is 2
what is the slope of B so what is B's
B's slope going to have to be what's
perpendicular a so it's going to be the
negative inverse of this the inverse of
2 is 1/2 the negative inverse of that is
negative 1/2 so B slope is negative 1/2
so we know that bees equation has to be
y is equal to its slope M times X plus
some y-intercept we still don't we still
don't know what the y-intercept of B is
but we can use this information to
figure it out we know that Y is equal to
negative 7 we know that Y is equal to
negative 7 when X is equal to 6 when X
is equal to 6 negative 1/2 times 6 times
6 plus B all right I'm just I just know
that this is on the point so this this
point must satisfy the equation of line
B so let's work out what B must be so
and this what or what the B the
y-intercept is the lowercase B not the
line B so we have negative 7 negative 7
is equal to what's negative 1/2 times 6
that's not a B there that's a
six what's negative 1/2 times 6 it's
negative three is equal to negative
three plus our y-intercept let's add
three to both sides of this equation so
if we add 3 to both sides I just want to
get rid of this 3 right here what do we
get the left-hand side negative 7 plus 3
is negative 4 and that's going to be
equal to these guys cancel out that's
equal to be our y-intercept so this
right here is a negative 4 so the
equation of line B is is y is equal to
its slope is a negative inverse of this
character so negative 1/2 negative 1/2 X
and its y-intercept we just figured out
is negative 4 minus 4 and we are done